what is this dating site I don't think
I'm gonna be gone in a few weeks we at
least just check it out for me or for
Mom I know that she would want you to
get back out there mostly really yeah
but no promises you signed on I'm so
proud and y'all ready got a message my
name is Alexis and she's hot too
I have a really good feeling about her
hi I'm Peter and you must be Alexis I
must be
a beautiful educated woman like yourself
a surgeon it's hard to believe you're
not attached well maybe I was just
saving myself at something like a
theater coming later I believe and I
think I speak repeater too and this is a
service something really really special
the hell is going on I've just met her
last time you actually you're in love
with her it's weird this whole dating
thing was your idea to begin with I know
that but what did he didn't know about
her what is all of this I think we
should speak you're hurting me
I knew things seemed to be going a
little fast fast are you insane
you just met my dad but taking over his
life
Lexie's got a rap sheet and I think
she's dangerous she's sick not right in
the mind
schizophrenia is what they tell us dad
you have to listen to me okay Lexi is
crazy stay away from her I'm mentally to
you or any other woman get in the way
what I want and what I deserve
I knew you were crazy from the first
time I laid eyes on you you've no idea
[Music]
you